enfin le suivi sur ceux plus forte
pression depuis le début de la pandémie
le dr vachon réalise toutes ces
consultations au téléphone
15% des patients viennent ensuite pour
un examen physique
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de consultations
ne se sont pas nécessairement en plus
d'éviter les contaminations la
télémédecine va gagner du temps aux
patients mais pas toujours aux médecins
par contre fait beaucoup des gens qui
sont à la maison isolée se sont super
contents de vous parler
les médecins spécialistes utilisaient
déjà la télémédecine mais seulement dans
certaines régions et le patient tout
comme le médecin devait être dans une
clinique médicale avant son départ
courage et tout le système était pour ne
pas favoriser la télémédecine alors que
maintenant on est obligé de s'adapter
j'espère que ce côté là vaut rester avec
l'arrivée de la coved on a vu une
accélération très rapide de
l'intégration de toutes ces technologies
là qu'on savait existantes mais qui
requérait ce sont tous ces petits
changements dans les lois et dans et
dans la proche à la pratique
mais il ya aussi certaines limites à la
télémédecine
on n'est pas le même plaisir de les voir
au tarif de 2 livres leur parler au
téléphone que d'avoir un contact une
meilleure personne manqueront père de ce
côté là je crois on perd aussi le non
dit des gens qui par exemple vivre un
moment difficile qui serait plus déprimé
c'est beaucoup plus facile à saisir si
on les voit personne il faudra bien
cibler les patients et leur laisser le
choix
mais la télémédecine pourrait bien aider
à désengorger le système de santé
on s'est bien rendu compte que la
télémédecine nous a redonné un moyen
commun parce que des gens qui n'ont plus
besoin d'aller justement à la clinique
puis d'être capable de bien se faire
servir
je pense qu'avec la télémédecine on voit
réduit le nombre de patients
ambulatoires pour des urgences vient
juste sol c'est près d'un million de
personnes par année
ben ça vaut la peine d'essayer
ici marie claude morin radio canada
montréal